loria
gloria viagra hier à deux ans la petite
gloria est en pleine forme elle ne
quitte pas d'une semelle sa maman
molinas hormis pour son entraînement
médical hebdomadaire
target
hockey
au moment où
gloria va toucher la cible moi je vais
sifflet et du coup c'est la cas c'est
qu'après la sa récompense son péché
mignon des morceaux de paume
malgré les barreaux de protection le
soigneur doit garder un lien pour
rassurer l'animal
target
ok
donc là on voit qu'elle est complètement
sur la balance donc si je me retourne je
vois qu'elle fait actuellement
5,6 ça veut dire que la reprise 10 kilos
depuis son dernier training à l'âge
adulte gloria pourrait atteindre deux
tonneaux le poids normal pour une
femelle hippopotame les mâles comme son
papa quid aux grossistes tout au long de
leur vie avec leurs canines pouvant
atteindre 60 cm il arrive qu'il y ait de
petits bobos on assure des blessures
très légères c'est juste qu'on va avoir
des marques sur la peau ça c'est le
principal c'est des griffures et sinon
après on peut avoir des problèmes de
dents dans la mâchoire en général mieux
que caen qui joue entre eux ils ouvrent
fort la gueule et peuvent se blesser
aussi à l'intérieur de la mâchoire et
quand il joue avec sa fille quid
n'hésite pas à montrer lits dont l'eau
reste le lieu privilégié de
l'hippopotame qui vit 80% de son temps
avec les popotins mêlée est pas capable
suer comme nous on transpire du coup il
ya la peau qui sèche très vite et il va
sécréter une
substance qu'on appelle de la sueur de
sang qu'un patrice il tente rouge qui va
lui permettre de protéger sa peau des
rayons du soleil il va pas être capable
de rester trop longtemps se laisser sa
peau va se craqueler et va blanchir du
coup il a toujours besoin d'être un peu
en contact avec de l'eau pour être le
mieux possible comme tout mammifères
l'hippopotame ne peux pas respirer sous
l'eau mais il peut rester en apnée
jusqu'à 30 minutes de quoi faire pâlir
les meilleurs plongeurs de la planète